wednesday edition pft pm shireen
williams mike florio and your
questions and you know i understand
we've been asking for questions two or
three times a week and sometimes we
don't have time to really answer many of
them well today
we do and we're going to get right to it
shireen at kvarp 23 has this question
via twitter who is the most underrated
player on the pittsburgh steelers
defense shireen your thoughts
it's a great question and i think the
answer is fairly obvious i think it's
tyson olulou the nose tackle you know
after they lost javon hargrave to the
eagles in the off season he's become the
primary nose and he's a big reason
really no pun intended here at the run
defense is number two overall but he's
actually done more than that he has a
sack he's affected the quarterback 13
tackles
three tackles for loss he's really been
a big part of that defense and i think
an underrated part of that defense we
always talk about the outside guys
because they're the ones who get the
sacks and the quarterback pressures and
and all of that sort of stuff and
they've been great no doubt about it but
they get enough pub this guy on the
inside is doing the dirty work and
getting it done
yeah and you know when they lost
hargrave to the eagles there was some
thought that maybe they wouldn't have a
classic nose tackle that they were in
the process of shifting toward more of a
4-3 look than a 3-4 look without that
traditional nose tackle lou has been
very good for them he was the first
round pick at the jaguars way back in
2010. i'm gonna go with cameron hayward
though because i think number one he's
awesome and number two he gets lost in
the shuffle pittsburgh defensive lineman
interior defensive lineman typically get
lost in the shuffle because it's the
linebackers that get the sacks and make
the tackles for the most part the way
the system is set up those guys in the
middle just clog up the line and grind
away and don't have the statistical
achievement that gets them the attention
yeah every once in a while a ball is
going to pop up in the air and cameron
hayward's going to catch it but for the
most part it's the bud duprees and the
tj watts who get the notoriety and it's
the guys grinding away in that front
wall that don't and hayward's a great
leader captain of the defense longtime
member of the team he was a first round
pick in 2011 the son of iron head
hayward a pittsburgh legend and i just
think he means a hell of a lot to that
team so much more that they don't quite
even realize it and they won't realize
it until he's no longer playing and it
was smart of them to get him signed to
an extension earlier this year shireen
and mike you know what i i think one big
thing to to talking about an absence i
think people are going to realize how
much devin bush meant to that defense uh
his loss is a huge one and i was talking
to a different scout an afc scout last
night and he talked about really how
much devin bush meant to that defense
and they're going to have hard time
replacing him and i think we're gonna
see it's not that he's underrated and i
wouldn't list him as underrated because
he was getting a lot of publicity but he
was a really integral part of that
defense and they still have the guys up
front but i do think they're gonna miss
him some
here's a great question from
papa pwn on twitter pick a team under
500 from each conference to make the
playoffs let's start with the nfc
shireen do you have one in mind
well i think there's two obvious
candidates right somebody has to win the
east i think unless they change the
rules which they probably should do
and that's either the eagles or the
cowboys and i just think the cowboys
have had too many injuries and
i hope that andy dalton doesn't get
killed this week but with the offensive
line that they're gonna throw out there
there's a good chance that his life is
in danger against this washington
defensive line which we know is very
good and because of all their injuries i
just don't think they're going to win
the division i think it's going to be
the philadelphia eagles so i'm going to
pick the eagles to make the playoffs by
default i don't know that they'll end up
with a winning record but because they
win the east they'll get in the
postseason and be one and done
you know i agree with you we've seen
this movie the past couple of years from
the eagles where they start slowly they
figure it out and i think it's going to
be easier this year to figure it out the
one caveat would be if washington flips
to alex smith and commits to him for the
rest of the season maybe they have a
chance to pull themselves back into it
but for now i'm going to say
philadelphia eagles i agree with you on
that how about in the afc a team under
500 that you think can make the playoffs
well i think the answer is obvious and
it's the new england patriots because
you know they're they're sitting there
at two and three but they're 13th on
offense and ninth on defense and you
just think that this is going to be a
team that's going to get better and
better considering the practices that
they missed over the last couple weeks
because of the covet issues i just think
they're going to be good and they're
going to be there at the end i think
they're going to end up with a winning
record because the patriots always end
up with the winning record they always
get to 10 wins maybe they don't get to
10 wins but i think certainly they get
to nine wins and the other team i think
you would kind of sort of look like look
at simply because they were without
their quarterback for a couple and
that's the denver broncos i think they
could get back and possibly be a factor
in that last playoff berth
and they're the only two teams that are
at two and three
the other teams below 500 in the afc and
there are five of them have one win or
fewer and overall there are 10 teams
right now in the nfl with one win or
fewer and one of the concerns we need to
keep an eye on because i know the league
is worried about this as teams slip out
of contention will they become less
concerned about avoiding covid19
infections or outbreaks because we're
done it's over we're not going to the
playoffs the one thing the players need
to remember if you don't play games
you're not getting paid so that's reason
alone to stay as healthy as you can but
they're very concerned about teams that
no longer are playing for anything being
as careful as they need to be about
staying away from covet 19. i agree with
you that the patriots are the team most
likely to turn it around i think the
longer they play together the better
they're going to be
and the question is going on the road in
the postseason can they beat some of
these teams and i i think of the best
teams in the afc right now the ravens
the chiefs the titans and the steelers i
think the last team they want to see and
in their initial playoff game would be
the new england patriots
yeah no question because you know what
bill belichick can do and he's going to
put together a great game plan and yes
maybe they're not going to go win the
division maybe they're not going to be
the top seed in the postseason but for
one game
i don't want to play bill belichick
james
906-38219 typically i'd beware the name
with a bunch of numbers afterward but in
this case we'll assume not a bot not a
troll and we'll answer james question
when is a b signing picked him up on my
fantasy team hey james 906 38219 nobody
cares about your fantasy team we'll
still answer the question shireen who do
you think he signs with and when
well you know seattle as pete carroll
said today is always in on these things
so i you know i don't know that seattle
particularly needs him and that's the
problem if you bring him into your
locker room you know you've got dk
metcalf you got tyler locket is he going
to be
divisive because he's not getting the
ball all the time and this is a guy that
only played one game last year and now
hasn't played yet this year so we know
he stays in great shape there's no
question about that but just not having
that game action is he still going to
demand the ball despite having not
played so i look at seattle just because
they're always in on these things but
you know other than that i don't know i
don't know that anybody else is just
going to be jumping up and down to sign
a b
you need to have coaching staff and or
team leaders that will ensure that
antonio brown is deferential and doesn't
cause problems and he needs to be on a
one strike arrangement where if he does
cause a problem out he goes last year
the seahawks were interested in him and
josh gordon they signed josh gordon he
got suspended they've signed him back
onto the team he hasn't been cleared yet
so i can see why they'd be interested in
antonio brown and i'm fascinated by the
possibility of some of these nfc
contenders
trying to box each other out to get
antonio brown because you don't want him
to go to the seahawks you can get him
and keep him from another team and tom
brady has wanted him he's made no bones
about it with all the injuries in tampa
how do you continue to resist the
argument that you should add antonio
brown because they never have the full
compliment of past catchers so put
antonio brown on the team i know bruce
arians wants nothing to do with them
based on their two years in pittsburgh
however and we'll see who's really got
the juice in tampa if they do go after
antonio brown then maybe it is tom
brady's team in 2020 and possibly beyond
last question at robert fenders why are
the cleveland browns fan base in media
acting like the team is two and four
instead of four and two shireen
it's the brown syndrome we have it at
texas a m we call it the aggie syndrome
you're just so beaten down right i mean
2002 was our last playoff birth to south
2007 was our last winning record even
longer than that that they won the
division i mean it's just year after
year after year that this team loses and
so you get used to them losing and we
all just wait for them to collapse and
also think that the jury's still out on
baker mayfield right i mean we don't
know what he is i don't think the browns
know what he is and he stunk it up the
other day and i'm sure the rib played a
part in the way he played but he he just
has not gotten it done the way that we
think he should get it done so i just
think it's the history there it's a
graveyard for quarterbacks and they just
haven't been good
i think the problem too is when they
come up against a really good team they
get smacked down they lost 38 six to the
ravens week one and then 38-7 to the
steelers week six they need to show that
they can contend with a great team now
they're fortunate there's only really
three great teams left on the schedule
the titans the ravens and the steelers
the raiders are kind of in between there
are six games they should win and to
their credit they have figured out how
to win the games they should win i think
10 wins is very possible but what's
gonna happen six seed seven seed go on
the road week one of the post season and
get smacked down by somebody so that's
what i think is causing people to be
concerned about the browns at foreign
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports